audition publique spéciale allocution du
chef de l'état emmanuel macron bien sûr
dans une heure maintenant et puis
spéciale également campagne européenne
avec trois têtes de liste qui vont se
succéder sur ce plateau avant donc
d'écouter tous ensemble le chef de
l'état a dévoilé ces mesures donc en
réponse au gilet jaune première invitée
c'est manon aubry de la france a soumis
ce bon soir dans ça merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté l'invitation des chefs
parlementaires du figaro et de la fp
dans 20 minutes c'est nicolas dupont
aignan qui vous succédera enfin
troisième invité ce soir ce sera le
centriste jean christophe lagarde avec
moi vincent route du figaro live
danseurs vincent et oriane mancini de
public sénat avec tout à l'heure
également brigitte boucher de lcp
assemblée nationale et polo bria de la
sp d'abord manon aubry donc emmanuel
macron je disais maintenant une heure de
son rendez vous décisif avec les
français quel est votre attente
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre quand un
débat a été élaboré avec des questions
biaisées
donc quand on regarde de près la manière
dont a été construit ce débat il visait
à répondre à des questions qui sont
celles élaborées par le président de la
république en gros est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous êtes prêts à faire pour baisser
la dépense publique parce que l'état
dépense plus que n y en a les moyens et
ce qu'il faut baisser la dépense
publique ou ou augmenter les impôts bien
sûr que c'est biaisé
vous le savez comme moi d'état par
exemple l'emprunt l'état emprunte à 0
25% sur les marchés financiers et le
taux d'inflation est de 2% dont
concrètement en empruntant de l'argent
et à gagner de l'argent et puis à aucun
moment et dans aucun cadre de ce débat
n'est posé la question véritable du
partage des richesses du rétablissement
de l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune
de plus grande progressivité de l'impôt
en même temps que ça c'était dans les
questions
vous n'attendez pas fini ça c'était dans
les questions ensuite sur la manière
dont 6 t il s'est déroulé en dehors du
fait qu'on a eu 1 2 % du corps électoral
qui a participé il ya quand même une
partie des contributions notamment la
moitié des contributions écrites qu'elle
n'a toujours pas été traités donc le
président de la république va prendre
seul des conclusions sur un débat qui
est peu représentatif de l'opinion
française et qui en plus de cela n'a pas
été traitée dans sa totalité
donc on voit que le débat était biaisé à
la fois sur sa forme sur ses modalités
et sur le fond donc je crois qu'il n'y a
pas grand chose à attendre dans la
mesure où lui même avait écarté
objectivement à la fois le
rétablissement du sf le la mise en place
du référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'est des choses qu'ils avaient
concrètement incarnez donc on va voir
c'est peut-être qu'il va les annoncer ce
soir mais le défend tout cas il
annoncera il annoncera des mesures il
annonce même une mesure choc une mesure
surprise qu'est ce que ça doit être pour
vous sept majeur je suis pas devin et je
suis pas avec de beaux lauriers envie
vous alors moi de ce que j'ai envie si
je peux faire ma liste au père noël
ma liste au père noël c'est une vraie
transformation sociale donc d'abord il
ya je crois que les revendications qui
sont exprimés en france depuis un
certain nombre de semaines et de mois
sont plusieurs ordres d'abord sur la
question démocratique il faut une
sixième république il faut changer de
ces institutions qui instaure une sorte
de monarque républicain et qui laisse
peu de place aux citoyens pour prendre
la parole c'était aussi le sens du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
il faut je crois c'est l'occasion aussi
de faire une grande révolution fiscale
c'est un sujet que je connais bien j'ai
bossé sur les questions de justice
fiscale pendant des années en fait ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières décennies
c'est que les gouvernements les uns
après les autres on fait une espèce de
petits ajustements de petits pansements
par exemple est ce que par exemple si le
chef de l'état annonce tout à l'heure
qu'il crée de nouvelles tranches par
exemple les ménages qui rentre dans
l'impôt est ce que ce serait selon vous
une mesure favorable aux classes
moyennes est ce que vous êtes sûr y est
favorable
là aussi
et c'est une mesure concrète contraire
bien sûr mais juste c'est bon c'est
prendre le problème par le petit bout de
la lorgnette
parce que en matière fiscale en matière
d'impôt sur le revenu nous vous
proposons 14 tranche d'impôt sur le
revenu pour le rendre véritablement plus
progressif
on sait qu'en france ces 20 dernières
années les impôts les plus injustes ont
augmenté la tva les recettes ont
augmenté de 73%
la csg les recettes ont été multiplié
par 6,7 en 20 ans et c'est des impôts
qui sont payés en plus forte proportion
par les plus pauvres et donc je le
disais je pense que c'était l'occasion
de faire une espèce de révolution
fiscale de remettre à plat notre système
fiscal pour leurs pensées et le rendre
plus juste à l'origine à l'origine de
cette révolte des gilet jaune notamment
est ce grand débat ya la révolte de
gilet jaune est à l'origine de la
révolte des jeunes
il y à la taxe carbone qu'est ce que
vous attendiez qu'est-ce que vous
attendriez que emmanuel macron annonce
ce soir à propos de la taxe carbone je
crois que la taxe carbone il faut la
laisser là où elle est dans les cartons
sur quelques cependant qu'elle est
suspendue et qu'elle soit suspendue de
manière définitive parce que que dit
cette taxe carbone je vous le disais
aujourd'hui on fait peser le poids
fiscal de plus en plus sur les classes
moyennes et les classes les plus pauvres
et la taxe carbone c'est typiquement ça
vous demander à des gens concrêtement de
payer davantage quand ils font leur
plein d'essence et le jury sans leur
donner des leçons mais n'avait
d'écologique que le nom parce que en
réalité déjà à la base n'était même pas
fléchir la transition écologique et en
plus ça veut dire qu'on fait payer la
transition écologique aux ménages les
plus qu'en mai mauvais mesures
compensatoires qui ont été prises de
bien chez eux
et qui prouve que les gilles exemple
voilà mais ce n'est pas suffisant ce
n'est pas suffisant par exemple pour
lutter efficacement contre le changement
climatique
on peut taxer davantage le kérosène qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas taxée et puis on
peut opérer une véritable révolution
écologique là aussi en investissant
massivement dans la transition
écologique
c'est clair ça coûte bientôt cet argent
faut aller chercher auprès des plus gros
pollueurs qui sont les plus riches et
les grands votre campagne va vous
conduire bientôt aux antilles la
guadeloupe martinique vous allez prendre
l'avion
si vous avez honte de prendre l'avion
mais je pense qu'il faut minimum réduire
en effet l'avion à tout le moins parce
que aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est
que l'avion est devenu un outil facile
quand on fait paris marseille je pense
que en effet il faut davantage prendre
le train et pour ça faut que rendre le
train attractif plus pour que finalement
notre choix naturel se portent vers le
train et pour qu'ils se portent vers le
train il faut diminuer les prix et pour
ça il faut sauver nos services publics
de la libéralisation et pour faire le
lien avec la campagne sur les
européennes
la libéralisation de la sncf elle a été
votée dans le troisième et quatrième
paquet ferroviaire pape et député
européen et célébrer la concurrence a
fait baisser les prix est ce que vous
avez sur l'énergie l'a exclu la
concurrence sur l'énergie ça fait
baisser les prix c'est l'opérateur qui
concurrençait de fauqué jo sur eux je
vous invite à tous ceux qui nous
regardent
est ce que votre facture de gaz et
d'électricité a baissé avec la
libéralisation de ce marché la réponse
est non avant de passer aux européennes
pour finir sur les annonces des manuels
mâcon qu'est ce que vous dites au gilet
jaune samedi est ce que vous dites le
président a parlé
il a annoncé des mesures il faut arrêter
de descendre dans la rue est ce que vous
dites quel que soit son discours
continuer de manifester samedi
ma réponse déjà je la ferai après les
annonces du président de la république
quand même non
1 bah oui mais enfin je laisse vous me
dites vous de voir quand vous demandez
vous me demandez ce que j'attends je
vous dis aux vues à la fois de la
manière dont s'est tenue le débat au vu
de ce qu'a été préannoncé parce qu'on a
quand même lui edouard philippe qui sa
seule compréhension faut le rappeler de
ce mouvement des jeunes et du débat
c'est que les gens demandent moins de
dépenses publiques non les gens ils
demandent en plus de ces gros impôts ya
une exaspération et donc qu'ils
comprennent ce que le gouvernement
comprend c'est chouette on va continuer
notre baisse des impôts des plus riches
attendait non ce que demandent les gens
c'est davantage de justice fiscale c'est
la progressivité de l'impôt c'est par
exemple la baisse de la tva avec un tva
à taux zéro sur les produits de première
nécessité sur le lait sur les pattes et
ça c'est interdit par l'union européenne
on peut soit faire un tva à un taux de
tva à taux zéro sur ces produits là
voilà une contrat reste il faut
récemment manon brille sur justement là
le nouvel acte dont qui se prépare ce
week-end les responsables bonheur
finalement il y avait remis aimé faire
plus mais bien de mobilisation très
forte qui sont annoncés avec une volonté
avec une volonté à chaque fois d'en
découdre
est ce que vous appelez les meneurs au
calme et à ne pas s'en prendre aux
forces de l'ordre à rester raisonnable
saleh depuis le début on a toujours
toujours dit que la violence n'était
jamais la solution à quelconque
revendication sociale de quelque nature
qu'elle soit donc nous change des black
blocs sur la gauche radicale
par contre on condamne la réduction la
volonté d'instrumentalisation politique
qui viserait à réduire l'ensemble d'une
mobilisation sociale à des violences par
ailleurs je pense qu'il faut aussi avoir
une fondation et condamnation ferme sur
les violences policières violences
policières sur lesquels le gouvernement
n'a eu aucun mot de gestation depuis le
début du mouvement a également
rassemblement du samedi
visez insurrectionnel puisque le mot
revient ce mode là où le condamné aussi
pour moi l'insurrection elle peut être
profondément citoyenne c'est une
insurrection de la part de gens de
femmes et d'hommes qui sont exaspérés
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'entendent pas se
ranger cachant social à et
insurrectionnelle mais insurrectionnelle
c'est l'instance pour moi et
l'insurrection défilé pacifique quand on
dira c'est votre interprétation maxi
maxi cie main mais la hook
là encore je suis désolé de vous le dire
vous résumer un mouvement social à des
violences qui sont tout à fait
condamnable qui ne sont pas la pollution
la solution mais qui sont réels mais qui
sont absolument pas représentatif si
vous vous voyez si on centralise le
débat autour de la question des
violences et qu'on ignore la
mobilisation qui a eu et qu'on ignore à
quel point ces revendications sont
partagés je veux dire là au point où on
en est et honnêtement la question se
pose plus en mode et ya un gilet jeune
homme qui n'a pas de gilet jaune
le rétablissement de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune plus de 70 %
des gens sont en faveur
le référendum mise cette citoyenne plus
de 75 % davantage de justice fiscale
en taux réduit et un tome 2 0 de tva sur
les produits de première nécessité ça
fait largement consensus alors qu'est ce
qu'on attend pour les mettre en place
avec vous dites que cette élection
européenne ça doit permettre d'infliger
une sanction emmanuel macron est-ce que
vous dénaturez pas cette élection alors
que les enjeux européens sont importants
non pour deux raisons la première c'est
que il ya eu on en parlait longuement
une mobilisation sociale dans les rues
depuis plusieurs semaines que le
gouvernement et emmanuel macron ne
semble pas entendre
s'ils ne sont pas capables d'entendre ce
qu'il se passe dans la rue alors il faut
pouvoir le faire entendre dans les yeux
puisque nous sommes citoyens il ça reste
une arme le bulletin de vote pour vous
ça devait être un réseau anti ou pro mac
contre la sélection et ce d'autant plus
que la réforme des retraites a été
laissé moins aller jusqu'au bout a été
repoussée à juste après les élections
européennes comme par hasard et par
ailleurs et c'est la deuxième raison est
d un élément de réponse
il y a un lien aujourd'hui entre les
politiques qui sont menées par un manuel
macron france et les politiques
européennes que ce soit la casse du code
du travail qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement des manuels macron juste
après son arrivée au pouvoir
c'est sous injonction de l'union
européenne par ailleurs en matière
fiscale
on assiste aujourd'hui en europe à une
course à la concurrence fiscale c'est
l'union européenne qui quand même il
faut rappeler est dirigée par le vrp des
paradis fiscaux jean claude juncker
aujourd'hui ne fait rien pour agir
contre l'évasion fiscale et alimentent
cette course et résultat les états les
uns après les autres multiplie les
cadeaux fiscaux aux procès
on vend les questions sur lesquelles on
va revenir sur la question des paradis
fiscaux on sait que c'est un de vos
chevaux de bataille mais d'abord un coup
d'oeil aux chiffres nouvelle livraison
ce matin du sondage louis harris
interactive notamment pour le figaro et
ils montrent une remontée de votre liste
à quoi vous l'attribué au retour de
jean-luc mélenchon dans la campagne
ça c'est la blague pour tout le monde
donc je peux le dire une bonne fois pour
toutes ça s'est pas fait j'en ai vu un
jour n'est pas le sauveur de notre quant
à elle il participe comme l'ensemble de
la france en soumises non je pense que
c'est c'est un mouvement collectif
évidemment que jean luc mélenchon il
participe c'est quelqu'un qui compte
aujourd'hui pour la france mais je crois
que c'est un mouvement collectif parce
que nous sommes en campagne depuis plus
de quatre mois
nous avons un programme on en parle
assez peu qui est disponible depuis
début décembre
et puis nous faisons campagne avec nos
eaux lovano camion hologramme qui font
tour de france 471 étape nous faisons
des ateliers des directives européennes
où nous écrivons des directives
européennes avec des citoyens
nous sommes présents partout sur le
territoire et nous mobilisons les gens
pour qu'ils ne laissent pas passer leur
chance pour ce 24 questions sur jean luc
mélenchon après on parle du fond d abord
vous dites n'est pas le sauveur c'est un
atout ou handicap la soixantaine s'étend
à tous c'est un atout sans ambiguïté
mais je pense que la france soumise et
forte de la diversité de ses atouts moi
j'étais pas la france est soumise avant
de mener cette campagne on a sur notre
liste des gens qui viennent d'horizons
différents on a un sergio coronado qui
vient d'europe écologie les verts même
des anciens socialistes avec emmanuel
maurel on a des gens qui veulent du
secteur associatif on à anne sophie
pelletier qui une aide soignante qui est
cinquième sur la liste et café une grève
pour notamment dénoncer les conditions
traitement des personnes âgées en ehpad
voilà la diversité de la france en sus
lisent ainsi que la diversité des
actions et je pense que c'est ça qui
commence à payer dans les images
encore un mot sur jean luc mélenchon
puisque j'ai lu dans le journal du
dimanche un portrait plutôt flatteur
pour vous qui savez comment votre
indépendance d'esprit et vous dit dans
cet article que vous ne faites pas
allégeance à jean luc marchand est ce
que vous pensez que ça va durer
longtemps
franchement est ce que la politique
c'est faire allégeance à 10 personnes
aujourd'hui nous recensons certains
partis
la france est soumise sachez que je sais
pas quelle image vous avez la france
insoumise non la jambe mais cui et ça il
le fait et en fait il le fait de manière
hyper respectueuse moi c'est quelqu'un
que je respecte beaucoup et on échange
beaucoup sur ce qui se passe en france
sur l'histoire politique
voilà je crois qu'on a une certaine
complicité et en même temps on est des
êtres humains qui sommes différents et
ça n'aurait aucun intérêt que ce soir
jeudi mais la question de fond d'accord
on va voir des questions de fond
justement avec jean luc mélenchon vous
êtes d'accord notamment sur la sortie
des traités mais avant puisqu'on parlait
de sondage vous avez déploré en meeting
à nîmes la semaine dernière quand j'ai
parlé un peu trop d'immigration que
l'immigration d'évasion fiscale lors du
dernier débat sur sur ses news mais
est-ce que c'est pas normal
je reviens au sondage harris interactive
qu'on a publié ce matin dans le figaro
l'immigration est le thème qui comptent
le plus dans la détermination du choix
pour les européennes savez des sondages
on a surtout il ya aussi d'autres
sondages qui disent linverse et puis il
ya des signes tulasne et dans quelle
mesure dans quelle mesure l'immigration
et le sujet qui est sortie pendant le
grand débat pendant longtemps les
maisons non mais sincèrement est-ce que
vous voyez des gens qui vont dans les
rues avec des pancartes en disant 'il
est greder est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est ça la préoccupation des gens au
quotidien mais j'assume de le dire que
ce n'est pas la préoccupation que je
suis pas est ce que vous avez dans un
espèce de déni par rapport à ceux ci
total dans un délire moi je pense qu'il
ya aujourd'hui une instrumentalisation
qui est fait en particulier par certains
médias en particulier par certaines
forces politiques qui en désignant les
émigrés comme des boucs émissaires en
disant ils sont responsables de tous vos
malheurs en faisant ça on des douanes
les vrais responsables
ce qui mène une politique économique en
faveur des plus riches ceux qui ne
s'occupe pas de ceux qui sont en galère
de d'augmenter la hausse du smic tient
une autre revendication qui est pas
prise en compte du tout par le
gouvernement est de venir en aide de ce
qu'ils sont ils en ont véritablement
besoin et je pense qu'on absolue
mauvaise solution ce genre c'est sûr ça
est ce que vous êtes par exemple
d'accord avec votre homologue allemande
sabine actes
élu de die linke donc l'équivalent de la
france a soumises en allemagne qu'il
faut limiter voire stopper l'immigration
de travail ou le recours à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère où aller ou des
travailleurs détachés ce pas tout à fait
ça qu'elle dit le la ligne condé qu'on
défend sur la question de l'immigration
c'est d'abord de rappeler à quel point
c'est une souffrance pour chaque une
personne qui a traversé les mers la
méditerranée les désert au péril de sa
vie et qu'il faut de vraies sur les
causes de cette les causes profondes de
cette souffrance que ce soit des accords
économiques qui maintiennent dans le
sous développement les pays en
développement
que ce soient les causes climatiques qui
va être la première cause des migrations
dans les années à venir
et qu'en même temps il faut accueillir
avec dignité des gens qui ont mis leur
vie en péril et qui n'ont d'autre choix
que de se retrouver jo je prends
chaussée de jambes là sur les
travailleurs de poche alors vous savez
que les travailleurs détachés on désigne
souvent les étrangers alors déjà c'est
un système européen et puis la cinquième
nationalité des travailleurs détachés en
france et des français
bon bah et ce sont ces sons d'autres
d'autres états européens
mais le problème des travailleurs
détachés c'est que on fait du dumping
social on nivelle par le bas les droits
sociaux et d'ailleurs le gouvernement se
vante d'avoir une réforme des
travailleurs détachés mais en réalité
les entreprises en france peuvent encore
payer des cotisations sociales dans les
pays d'origine du coup elles font leur
marché et sa baisse à protection sociale
de tout le monde et on est tous victimes
c'est pour ça qu'il faut rien question
sur une frite et sortir des traités
sortir des traités c'est ce que vous
dites mais sans sortir de l'union
européenne concrètement comme vous
faites alors concrètement pour bien
comprendre ce dont on parle d'abord il
faut comprendre en quoi les traités
européens sont un obstacle n'est pas
dogmatique ce qu'on dit c'est purement
pragmatique les traités européens
empêche aujourd'hui l'harmonisation
sociale et fiscale
il empêche d'investir massivement dans
la transition écologique avec la règle
des 3% de déficit il empêche de faire du
protectionnisme solidaire en mettant des
taxes à nos frontières pour protéger
notre économie
je le dise que c'est important de
comprendre les gens savent pas ce que
c'est les traités européens franchement
désigne ce truc
on ne comprend pas maintenant ce que
nous nous proposons si on est conscient
de ses freins et des obstacles et on dit
pour mener notre politique de progrès
social fiscal et écologique et
démocratique il faut rompre avec ces
règles donc on a plusieurs solutions
soit on essaie de renégocier
collectivement ces traités européens
j'ajoute que des traînées alliés en asie
parce que vous
est un peu seul sur ce qui est bien
c'est là où la stratégie du rapport de
forces est important d'abord il faut
avoir en tête et des traités européens
il y en a eu en moyenne tous les cinq
ans et vingt dernières années qu'ils ne
sont pas inscrits dans le marbre
ensuite la france c'est la deuxième
économie européenne la france pèse 18 %
d'économie européenne et donc contribuer
à hauteur de 16 milliards d'euros par an
ce sont des outils que nous pouvons
utiliser dans le rapport de force et
dire que quoi qu'il arrive ces règles de
3% de déficit fort par exemple avec la
commission européenne et avec l'allemand
qui sont venus alors si ça va pas
marcher comme ça ça veut dire sortir de
l'europe mais enfin vous avez déjà
répondu sur cette question restera plus
qu on jette pas le bébé avec l'eau du
bain et on se donne les moyens d'accord
dans père et un changement radical de
cette union va mieux les portugais sont
d'accord sur sa peau des mois ces bleus
quoi bien sûr j'étais ce week-end au
sommet du plan b avec nos alliés
européens de partout en europe qui
soutiennent cette vision là et qui
prouve qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
isolés dans cette vision là et
d'ailleurs on est profondément
internationaliste à tous ceux qui
pensent qu'on est replier sur nous-mêmes
non on défend une vision de la
coopération entre les peuples
mais sur d'autres bases d'accord très
bien certains disent oui mais en mettant
le pistolet sur la tempe un seul yannick
jadot qui dit ça c'est sûr ma soeur soit
a sion c'est juste que dde je réponds là
dessus c'est juste que nous on se donne
les moyens de le faire et donc on n'est
pas à promettre qu'on va changer
l'europe
quand on n'a pas la capacité de le faire
c'était par des fils qu on encore les
lyonnais allaient sortir de l'union
européenne mais lesquels alors la
question c'est pas ce qu'il faut les
sortir ou pas c'est qu'il faut avoir des
sanctions qui trouve donc d'abord il
faut rappeler aux gens qui le suivent
parce que d'abord la liste européenne
des paradis fiscaux aujourd'hui c'est 15
et à celle des îles samoa
c'est l'île d'aruba des pays qui nous
renvoie on parle d'eux comme le
luxembourg et l'irlande
et pour ça il faut mettre des sanctions
à l'encontre de ces paradis fiscaux
concrètement c'est une taxe pour les
entreprises qui opèrent dans ces pays là
et qui n'ont pas d'activité économique
réelle comme google amazon et bien
d'autres iront pourrait le faire déjà à
l'échelle franco française encore
faut-il de l'ambition politique ce qui
manque en la matière de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale pour ça qu'il nous
faut des parlementaires
message est passé dernière question
madame le pen hier a dit qu'elle avait
des points d'accord avec la france
insoumise est ce que vous vous avez des
points d'accord avec marine le pen
moi j'en vois pas elles sont contre la
hausse du smic nous sommes pour ils sont
pour la cense vème république nous
sommes pour une sixième république
position haute alsace et alors que vous
allez irait chercher les votes de madame
le pen sur le taf talent était également
absent qu'un accord par le mans cup est
un gars que c'est votre jour 10 contre
bas et s'est toujours dit content sauf
que ya ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on fait et
ce qu'elle fait elle ne l'a pas fait
merci vous voyez rien de couverts
j'adore ces tentatives que l'on peut
dénoncer très bien merci à vous d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui nous vous
libérons et c'est donc nicolas dupont
aignan qui va entrer et prend dans votre
place
nicolas dupont aignan bonsoir et merci
d'être là avec brigitte boucher qui nous
a rejoint toujours aux côtés de vincent
rouge du figaro live donc on évoquait le
grand débat vers se rapproche pour le
chef de l'état qui doit importer donc
ses réponses est également bien sûr à la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes quel est
votre attente est ce que vous avez vous
un espoir
j'attendais d'écouté parce que il faut
toujours écouter avant de juger la
politique réglementaire mais je suis
inquiet parce que j'ai le sentiment que
le grand débat a été bien organisé pour
que surtout les solutions qu'attendent
les français ne sortent pas de ce grand
débat alors on verra si le président de
la république continue à se mentir à
lui-même et à faire croire que il faut
continuer la même politique
si vous étiez à la place du président
quelle mesure vous prendriez pour mettre
fin cette crise des gilet jaune
d'abord je crois que c'est il n'y a pas
de solution dans le cadre actuel
notamment des traités européens
parce qu'en vérité soit le président
s'exonère des traités vous revendiquez
effectivement d'avoir des points
d'accord avec la personne qui était là
avant vos listes de ceux qui veulent
remettre en cause des traités européens
qui nous ligotent et qui ont créé le
problème français et qui font que chaque
président de la république se présente
avec un programme et à la fin applique
celui de madame merkel ce qui est quand
même gênant il n'y a pas de réponse
nationale appuie sur leur civilisation
des retraites sur sur la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu bien sûr mais pour
apporter ses réponses et notamment je
propose depuis le début la ré indexation
des pensions de retraite
la baisse de la csg pour tous retraités
travailleurs un tgv à à taux zéro pour
certains produits de première nécessité
et une baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu
sur les premières tranches et enfin nous
l'avons justement nous sommes le seul
parti à debout la france à avoir proposé
32 milliards d'économie budgétaire
chiffré mais avec la remise en cause
justement des 11 milliards que nous
donnons à bruxelles pour revenir à 2
comme du temps de jacques chirac
avec la remise en cause de la fraude
sociale considérable notamment les
fausses cartes vitale avec la fin de
toute prestation sociale à des étrangers
qui arrivent sur notre sol pendant cinq
ans le temps qu'ils contribuent au pays
et avec la recherche bien sûr d'une
meilleure lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
notamment la pose à la tv vous l'enlevez
sur les revenus du patrimoine sur les
revenus fonciers sur les romans sur les
retraités et les revenus du travail
c'est fondamental pour pourquoi parce
que le problème du pays c'est quoi c'est
que le salaire net est trop faible
il n'est pas question d'augmenter le
salaire brut parce que sinon nos
entreprises feront faillite et donc la
seule marge possible pour réconcilier
les français et l'entreprise pour vivre
de son travail avec davantage de revenus
que de l'assistanat c'est à linverse de
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement sur les
retraités c'est de baisser la cg nous
l'avons chiffré 3% dans un premier temps
ce qui représente quand même une
certaine somme et il y aller
progressivement
mais je veux dire une chose les français
n'attendent pas simplement un jeu de
promesses fiscales à bon compte
il faut les économies et il ya aussi des
moyens de gagner du pouvoir d'achat avec
un point très simple la remise en cause
des privatisations notamment des
autoroutes notamment la fin de l' usine
à gaz de la fixation du prix de
l'électricité qui va augmenter de 6%
après les élections sur youtube
nous pourrions tout à fait éviter cette
hausse de l'électricité qui s'explique
uniquement par le système qui a été mis
en place suite à la signature des
traités européens
alors vous parlez de des tarifs de
l'énergie un gros problème à aider f
vous avez vu aujourd'hui qui est perclus
de dettes avec un plan qui est envisagée
par le chef de l'état avec notamment à
une privatisation partielle de certaines
mères actives et c'est peut-être une
nationalisation plus servi
nationalisation de tout le dispositif
nucléaire comment est-ce que vous
réagissez d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui
une épaule de bouche de plancher très
simplement réalisant que il est
scandaleux qu'on augmente le tarif de
l'électricité pour financer les
concurrents d'edf
nous avions une entreprise intégrée qui
marchait très bien
edf et gaz de france ils ont déposé gaz
de france et maintenant ils vont vendre
angie au privé je suis totalement
hostile à cet éclatement d'edf il faut
garder un groupe intégré 100% public qui
a permis à la france d'avoir
l'électricité la moins chère d'europe
pour nos industriels d'au moins chère
d'europe pour nos industriels et le taux
de carbone
nous produisons avec l'électricité
française six fois moins de carbone que
les allemands est dix fois moins que les
polonais alors arrêtons quand on veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
nous avions une entreprise performante
qui a été cassée qui aboutit à ce que
les français payent très cher
l'électricité qui aboutit à une
désorganisation quand on a quelque chose
qui marche dans notre pays évitons le
casser si monsieur macron veut faire
avec edf ce qu'il fait scandaleusement
avec aéroports de paris
déposez les biens publics jusqu'aux liés
dupont-aignan oublier les français
nicolas dupont aignan le jeu nous
l'attendrons au tournant monsieur macro
juste après un ep je veux m'en détacher
oui pardon sur un dépliant justement
quand j'ai moi si je me trompe mais j'ai
pas eu l'impression que vous avez signé
l'appel à un référendum
j'aurais mais ils s'engageraient on ne
m'a pas consulté puisque le sectarisme
de certains républicains fait que ça
devrait faire signer avec les
socialistes que signé avec moi même où
marine le pen
j'aurais été ravi de signer en tout cas
les militants debout la france feront
tout pour qu'il y ait ces quatre
millions cinq cent mille signatures
il faut bloquer la privatisation d'adé
paix qu'est le plus grand conflit
d'intérêt qui existe qui est un scandale
national aucun conflit d'intérêts parce
que c'est curieux c'est la bank of
america qui est chargé de la
privatisation et bien je trouve ça bien
curieux et vous remarquerez que monsieur
azémar vinci qui est
qui figurent parmi les plus de chances
de vinci qui serait vinci qui rackettent
les français sur les autoroutes
depuis des années et qui maintenant à
qui on donnerait un bien public
moi je vais vous dire cette affaire
d'aéroports de paris si j'étais le
président de la république vous
demandiez ce qui ferait ce soir je
renoncerai à cette affaire tient j'étais
dans le train en sortant en rentrant de
montpellier où j'avais un meeting samedi
et il ya une dame dans le train qui
avaient voté maquereau au premier tour
et qui est venu me voir et qui m'a dit
monsieur je suis tellement scandalisée
qui vante tout il vend nos biens c'est
notre argent c'est nous qui avons
construit tout ça cet homme finalement
j'ai découvert qu'il était la concession
pour 70 ans et pas de bruit sur 8 ou 70
ans non mais c'est vrai dans 70 ans
rendez vous serait encore en vie moi pas
mais faut arrêter se moquer des gens on
est ce que c'est normal que les biens
publics
vous avez les barrages hydroélectriques
la commission européenne nous oblige
scandaleusement à vendre les barrages
hydroélectriques
j'ai pas si vous réalisez l'importance
que ça pour l'irrigation l'utilisation
de l'eau la sécurité de nos concitoyens
il faut investir beaucoup dans les
aéroports est ce que vous croyez que
qu'un problème
l'autre d'or vous allez me raconter est
ce que vous connaissez un français qui
vend un bien qui lui rapporte pour
placer l'argent dans une banque où il va
pas lui rapporter parce que si
l'objectif non pas investir dans
l'innovation excusez moi
arrêtons ça c'est la logorrhée du pauvre
monsieur le maire qui devra répondre un
jour devant la cour de justice sans
doute de cette affaire parce que moi
j'aimerais carillon de l'écran actuel il
ya eu des privatisations dans le passé
ce que j'ai dit oui c'est grave
j'accuse le gouvernement d'organiser la
spoliation du bien public et je vais
vous dire une chose quand vous avez un
bien qui vous rapporte beaucoup je vois
pas l'intérêt de le vendre de se priver
des dividendes pour placer l'argent dans
des obligations qui rapportent quasiment
rien et utiliser le fruit de cet argent
pour l'innovation
il ya une solution beaucoup plus simple
que monsieur le maire utilise l'argent
des dividendes d'aéroports de paris pour
le placer pour l'innovation directement
ça évitera de se priver d'un bien
donc dans ses arguments de sa rivale
gérer notamment des grandes surfaces
parce que c'est tout cas si les
républicains
les socialistes et tous les bancs de
l'assemblée il ya unanimité
si au sénat le sénat a voté contre c'est
que quand même ça fait beaucoup
et j'aimerais que ce soit le président
de la république mais c'est quand même
bon coup dans une curieuse coalition
hétéroclite aussi en tout cas ça fait
beaucoup de vent des biens des français
l'autre l'autre mesure qui a été le
beaucoup réclamé au cours de ce grand
débat c'est le rétablissement liez vous
êtes pour vous est pourri bien
évidemment le emmanuel macron a donné 5
milliards d'euros aux plus riches de
france et a supprimé la paix elle réduit
la pl ces trois milliards et demi parce
qu'ils allient plus l'impôt sur le
capital
les facilités pour le truc c'est
ahurissant
une savate portera l'état sur le
rétablit un seul alors moi j'avais une
proposition pour la présidentielle qui
était une proposition de bon sens
c'était zéro isf pour ceux qui
investissent dans des entreprises qui
produisent sur le sol français
c'était un moyen de garder le bâton et
d'ajouter la carotte
car l'enjeu c'est pas bien sûr de faire
fuir les capitaux
c'est de les amener en france donc ma
solution zéro et isf pour les capitaux
placés sur le sol français était une
très bonne solution et je regrette que
le gouvernement et donner un cadeau
fiscal aux plus riches de france
en échange sans doute du financement de
sa campagne et puisqu'on a vu dorénavant
on a eu les résultats que ce sont les
contribuables de londres qui ont abondé
le compte de campagne de manière
extraordinaire de monsieur macron tout
ça est très choquant très choquant et je
crois qu'on peut pas sacrifier les
français et faire des cadeaux aux très
riches en temps de l'europe entend de
votre engagement lors l'europe
maintenant alors peut-être sur un mot
sur les sondages puisque vincent a
évoqué les sondages enfin vous étiez
parti un peu un peu aulas au début et
puis là vous êtes un peu retombée
finalement leur père que j'ai l'âge de
115 ans
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors je vais
vous dire je ne crois pas un instant à
ces sondages et je veux dire que j'ai
des sondés falloir maintenant je veux
dire vous étiez à lui raconter plein
d'optimisme je vais vous dire une chose
tab horizon il y en a eu 1 à 8 il y en a
eu à saint cannat u13 et demi en a eu 1
6 7 7 et je vais dire une chose mais je
vais vous dire une chose je me souviens
très bien aux dernières européennes
j'ouvre un jour bâtir c'était le figaro
que je m'étais très favorable j'imagine
et qui nous sortait un sondage c'est
assez barbe
c'est à cette curieuse un sondage 05
européenne trois semaines avant 2014
sondage dans la région grand-est 0,5
on a le moral dans les chaussettes
canton à son âge à 0,5
trois semaines après connaissez le
résultat j'ai eu quatre ennemis je crois
dans la région grand est dont eux seuls
pour 106% 4% 7%
je vais vous dire je suis absolument
convaincu qu'on fera un très bon score
parce que les français ne vont quand
même pas voter républicain monsieur
bellamy qui a voté ça vous pourriez le
dire dans votre journal qui a voté le
traité de marrakech c'est à dire tous
les députés républicains ont voté en
avril 2018 sous traité de marrakech
ils ont voté l'élargissement la serbie
ils ont voté les 14 milliards d'adhésion
de la turquie pour la pré adhésion de la
turquie
donc monsieur bellamy des choses très
justes parfois il reprend beaucoup de
choses que je connais sur l année à 14%
marine le pen a dit que mathématiquement
si vous aviez été ensemble
mathématiquement vous auriez tnt
aujourd'hui alors je vais vous dire est
ce que vous pensez vous pensez qu'elle
se trompe louis complètement journal
rapport quoi monsieur macron a besoin de
madame le pen comme assurance vie
c'est un scrutin à un tour
proportionnelle est ce que monsieur
bellamy fait une liste commune avec
madame loiseau pourtant les républicains
ont soutenu ce matin les mêmes idées à
temps partagé lémanique ne partagent
exactement la matinée ils votent
ensemble au parlement européen ppe est
un parti fédéraliste
si vous reprenez tous les votes des
députés république n'a pas de député la
république en marché avec eux ceux ci on
a des députés socialistes qui sont ceux
qui soutiennent le gouvernement
si vous reprenez les votes ils votent
ensemble est ce que monsieur dès la mi
fait une liste commune avec madame
l'oiseau pourtant monsieur fillon et les
républicains ont tous soutenu monsieur
macron j'ai soutenu madame le pen
j'assume et je maintiens qu'il fallait
faire barrage à emmanuel macron pour
autant je suis pas marié avec madame le
pen en éveil nous avons deux partis
différents
c'est un scrutin à un tour avec une
pluralité de livres du poignant qu'on
laisse les français choisir et qu'on a
fermé le parlement attendait chez soleil
ma phrase qu'on enferme pas les français
dans un pseudo course de petits chevaux
entre en marche et le rassemblement
national car c'est pas l'objet désormais
vous dit c'est pas l'objet vous dit vous
avez vous éviter ça deux parties donc le
rassemblement national de vous la france
bleu île
et quand on regarde les programmes à
l'écran des idées c'est l'europe des
nations j'ai lu c'est le rôle des grands
projets en ya des points communs elles
sont belles et on voit pas du tout ce
qui vous décorer vertement des pointes à
la maison on ne voit pas les différences
j'y vais venir alors répondez à cette
question arrêté par le désordre avec
vous mais il faut comprendre des choses
ouais il ya beaucoup de points communs
entre monsieur bellamy entre madame
oiseaux puisque les différences entre
nos magasins
alors je vais vous dire il ya des points
communs et que j'assume
et heureusement et il ya des différences
notamment une différence fondamentale
c'est sur les alliés nous n'avons pas du
tout les mêmes alliés au parlement
européen nous avons signé un accord avec
23 parties 23 c'est la première fois
qu'un accord aussi large
le 28 février dernier sont tous venus à
paris
monsieur thierry beaudet cas veut gagner
des élections aux pays bas par exemple
pour le forum pour la démocratie c'est
pas du tout le même esprit que monsieur
garde builders est dans le groupe de
madame le pen e
nous avons les polonais nous avons des
tchèques nous avons des finlandais etc
nous avons 23 nationalités c'est un
groupe modéré modère ses petits modèles
oui regardez les travailler les affaires
européennes comme vous le savez faire
vous verrez que ça n'a rien à voir ce
n'est pas le f p o
ce n'est pas bien des alliés européens
sont fréquentables pendant ce même s'ils
sont fréquentes à moi j'ai jamais joué
jeu là en revanche ce c'est le troisième
groupe du parlement européen exemple
c'est le troisième a fait un meeting
commun avec marine le pen grazia meeting
commun c'est le troisième groupe du
parlement européen
c'est un groupe important c'est un
groupe qui partage notre idée de la
subsidiarité
c'est à dire si je peux pas insisté un
point c'est une autre différence
d'autres projets très clair nous ne
voulons pas la fin de l'europe nous
voulons la fin de l'union européenne et
nous voulons une europe des nations et
des problèmes avec le pen dit la même
chose il va surtout en plus bien sûr je
les comprends votre influence qu'elle
allait renoncer à l'euro et qu'elle
avait juste autres aujourd'hui tient
renoncer une sortie de l'union veut
différent vous pouvez vous pouvez ce
qu'on sépare ils ne parlent que de mal
vous pouvez le premier ministre de
marine le pen et son adversaire je suis
pas son adversaire dès que vous n'êtes
pas non mais vous n'avez pas les mêmes
allié alors je reprends est ce qu il ya
un problème de compréhension lui demeura
comme sur la tête
monsieur bellamy ne sera pas dans le
même groupe que monsieur en marche ppe
est un groupe libéral d'accord et pour
autant ils vont voter des directives
ensemble nous ne serons pas dans le même
groupe que marine le pen mais nous
aurons des votes commun je l'espère mais
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas des nuances
nous n'avons pas les mêmes alliés pas la
même tête de maladie et aider les jeunes
et madame tout le monde parle de la
liste de madame le pen elle n'est pas
candidate
ça aurait peut-être été différent s'il
avait été candidate elle n'est pas que
vous auriez rejoint une légère vibration
le pen jeudi matin mais elle n'est pas
candidat alors il faut que les français
sachent qu'ils en voient là bas mais
vous je suis candidat mais oui mais il
ya des doutes qui ont surgi récemment
robots des moules alimentaires par des
valeurs basées l'occasion vous est
donnée nicolas du point là je sais vous
démissionner de votre président mais je
suis obligé mais pour qu'on a là
l'horreur vous avez ce que vous vous
engagez pour les besoins de jeunes
étaient peut-être plus donc je serai pas
candidat à la mairie d'hyères en 2020
mais nous oui c'est quoi cette histoire
j'ai vu ça dans la presse c'est bon bah
c'est complètement faux puisque la
personne ne m'a même pas appeler parce
que ce cas 52 voix alors insulté ferrand
sernancelhe en pour aller au parlement
européen c'est pour ça qu'on a un goût à
givet parce que c'est historique ce qui
va se passer
et pourquoi je pense que la liste que je
conduis avec ses 23 alliés et la qualité
des personnes qui sont dessus je pense à
stéphanie j bourg lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale lanceuse dallaire de la sphère
ubs je pense à benjamin cauchy
je pense au président du cni paix bruno
north bref jamais empêché qu'on a
beaucoup plus haut sur les ronds pour
tout à fait et j'en suis fier qu'ils
nous aient rejoints comme gilet jaune
je pense que nous aurons à négocier avec
des partenaires sérieux
les 23 un bouleversement de l'union
européenne et je pense qu'il est bon
qu'une personnalité française nationale
qui s'investissent car moi j'y vais pas
pour faire un score là j'y vais parce
qu'on a une occasion historique de
changer complètement le fonctionnement
l'union européenne de marine le pen
pourquoi fait part à ce grand groupe
veut par le 23 bis karski l'émir plus
important peut-être que c'est madame le
pen qui ou des gens qui râlent abl
il nous rejoindra si vous connaissiez
mieux les affaires européennes vous
sauriez que le groupe crc le troisième
groupe de l'assemblée
si c'est le cas ça sera sans doute
regarder des polonais si vous regardez
les scores de la chance c'est bien sûr
une question l'objet de la campagne une
question nicolas dupont aignan puisque
par les membres de votre liste pourquoi
vous avez évincé jean frédéric poisson
malgré vos acteurs écrivains ce qui
laissait le 18 mars dernier parce qu' il
s' est exclue de lui-même
voilà ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire il
a essayé de faire unique dans notre dos
et s'est pas aidé mentalement loyal il
avait va bien et bien les journalistes
du figaro ont confirmé pour une fois
voyez le figaro a confirmé ce groupe les
chrétiens ne cherchez pas des cons
croyable car s'il ya une personne qui a
défendu les chrétiens d'orient avec
debout la france et d'ailleurs je suis
ému là parce qu'il ya notre dame qui est
en train de brûler et j'espère que c'est
pas un attentat en tout cas c'est
dramatique pour notre pays non non on
n'en sait rien on vient me le dire on
attend on alterne notation comme je vais
vous dire moi je n'aime pas ce qu'on
fait en désaccord en politique mais je
n'aime pas lancer des anathèmes sur les
personnes ce qu'ils ressentent au plus
profond d'eux mêmes
donc notre liste défend des valeurs d
une civilisation européenne et je
n'accepte aucune
comment dire base attaque la loyauté
c'est la première valeur chrétienne je
l' ai appris à l'école
merci à notre dame c'est un accident dit
la préfecture nicolodi mais bon c'est
vrai qu'il ya une enquête bien sa mesure
dans malvenue merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre avis merci à vous
aujourd'hui
maintenant vous avez cédé la place à
jean christophe lagarde pour la vie
bonsoir jean christophe lagarde
président de l'udps et les centristes du
lude et merci d'être avec nous paul
briat nous rejoint toujours aux côtés de
vincent roux vous avez écouté les deux
précédents intervenants jean christophe
lagarde alors vraiment que des critiques
qui pleuvent sur l'europe on l'entend là
durant cette campagne
depuis le début de cette émission tout
le monde veut changer corrigé l'europe
ses défauts et ses terres est ce que
vous vous avez envie quand même de nous
livrer sur quelques minutes peut-être
une minute une profession de foi
européenne
écoutez c'est pas très compliqué tout ce
que vous entendez critiquer l'europe en
règle générale disent qu'il faut en
sortir
alors certains disaient qu'il fallait en
sortir et puis maintenant se cache un
peu parce que quand on regarde la grande
bretagne on ne peut pas dire que ça fait
envie 1
un tel bazar un tel affaiblissement un
tel isolement moi je dis que la solution
n'est pas dans la sortie de l'europe
elle est dans sa transformation parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses qu'il
faut corriger en europe d'accord mais
pas dans la sortie sans même en utiliser
le biais évidemment de la révision de la
sortie des traités on entend ça nous
avons entendu ces gens regardent le
rapport ces gens là sont du monde si
vous sortez les tracts et vous sortez
vous vous sortez de l'europe à ce qu'on
entend de la réalité c'est qu'il faut
changer un certain nombre de traités ça
c'est vrai pourquoi parce que l'europe
est passée à côté du tournant de
l'histoire depuis la chute du mur de
berlin qu'est ce qui s'est passé on nous
a dit c'était la fin de l'histoire est
en vérité c'est le début d'une autre
histoire des puissances continentales
qui se sont constitués la chine les
etats unis l'inde et ses puissances
continentales nos pays séparé ne
parviendront pas à ne pas subir le roi
leurs lois leurs règles leurs intérêts
croyait donc il faut rassembler à l'art
puissance encore jean chrétien mais
encore voyez alstom vise à ce vous
croyez encore à la leur puissance c'est
justement parce que alstom et siemens a
été décidée dans le cadre d'un traité
qu'il faut corriger
qu'est ce que c'était elle somme siemens
c'était 35 trains 35 tgv parents que
l'europe a refusé que la commission a
refusé de laisser se constituer pourquoi
simplement parce que lisez ça va être un
problème de concurrence interne à
l'europe résultats chaye yo et 450 tgv
par an est en train de construire la
première ligne entre la terre et
budapest changer l'europe comme je le
propose c'est faire en sorte qu'elle se
donne les moyens de résister elle
construit sa puissance continentale pour
résister aux autres comptes
continental si plaisant quand on en
parle mais ça se fait pas non ce n'est
pas vrai il ya cinquante ans on a
commencé à faire l'europe pour faire la
paix on a fait des projets communs pour
éviter d'avoir des intérêts divergents
il ya du temps de giscard d'estaing et
des chevilles et ensuite du terran et
cool on a décidé de faire un grand
marché pour booster l'économie et ça a
marché vous savez qu'on échange
aujourd'hui autant avec la belgique avec
les états unis c'est pas la même taille
deux pays
ce que nous n'avons pas fait c'est la
suite c'est le projet des fondateurs de
jean monnet de ses héritiers dont nous
sommes je vois séance elle de faire
ensemble pas une parce qu'on apprend qu
emmanuel macron reporte son allocution
télévisée ce soir en raison de l'
incendie qui ont évoqué il ya un
incident sur une aura un autre match que
je peux vous dire qu'en venant pas très
loin d'ici on voyait la volute de fumée
etc etc c'est consternant fais
bouleversant de voir ce joyau de notre
patrimoine national de notre histoire
partir en fumée comme on le voit sur ces
images alors c'est pas si on nous
confirmait de selon la préfecture les
informations à l'instant qu'il s'agirait
donc bien d'un d'un incendie accidentel
un tous les cas je l'espère je
l'imaginais j'imagine que personne est
assez dingue pour s'attaquer à ce bijou
notre histoire à notre histoire et notre
identité nationale c'est ça notre dame
de paris
bien que dans le climat actuel
évidemment du pays cela évidemment va
encore peut-être tendre des esprits non
parce que je ne suggérerai inquiétudes
je ne crois pas et je n'espère pas la
thèse de la porte de l'attentât et donc
si c'est un accident c'est un accident
au contraire c'est peut-être un outil de
rassemblement parce que comme moi je
suis prêt à donner pour que la mairie de
paris re construit notre dame aussi
belle que nous l'avons connue avant ce
qui est en train de se passer et je
pense qu'ils les millions de français
qui seraient prêts à donner un peu
d'argent pour faire en sorte qu'on
restaure notre histoire notre patrimoine
un peu de nous quoi et la décision du
chef de l'état bien sûr c'est qu'à
raison de reporter son allocution
je pense qu'il a raison parce que
ils seraient comme en virage bizarre que
le président de la république parle du
grand débat au moment où on connaît un
grand drame pour revenir sur l'europe et
sur les élections européennes est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dit
nous sommes réalistes nous égayer la
plus pro europe
est ce que c'est un petit peu vous
appelez les européens c'est bon de votre
visite ça veut dire ça nous sommes prêts
encore davantage pour l'europe que par
exemple la république en marche et
nathalie noiseau mais vous savez dans
cette élection il ya des gens qui
veulent démolir l'europe il ya des gens
qui veulent pas beaucoup la changer
c'est la liste de monsieur marc dal maso
et il ya des gens qui disent pour la
sauver pour la transformer il faut là
concentrée la recentrer sur ce qui est
stratégique sur quoi en réalité sur ce
que nos pays ne peuvent plus faire
efficacement ce je vous prends un
exemple il ya une obsession en ce moment
de taxer les gaffes à moi je dis que
pour tendant le bras ou gafa pour rendre
le modèle vertueux on a besoin d'avoir
une loi européenne qui 1 donne le droit
à chacune et chacun d'entre nous d'être
propriétaires de nos données et oblige
les gaffes à nous payer lorsqu'elles
font des milliards avec nos données
concrètement quand vous surfez sur
internet
à chaque fois que vous cliquez elle
aspire ce que vous êtes ce que vous
faites c'est à vous et elles font des
milliards avec ça elles ont droit de
vendre ces données mais dans ces cas là
doivent nous les payer elle doit vous
les payez à chacune et chacun d'entre
nous pour que l'on retrouve un système
vertueux économique qui permet que
certes il utilise des données pour
offrir des services
mais il paye aujourd'hui en fait ces
nouveaux pétroles et il se trouve que ce
nouveau pétrole il ne le paye pas et je
reconnais que je suis le seul à dire ça
en france peut-être même en europe
mais je suis pas le seul à dire non dans
le monde yuval noël harari le pdg de
samsung
le gouverneur de la californie le pays
de la silicon valley disent la même
chose que moi et voilà un exemple de ce
que l'europe doit faire pour se
rassembler et pour faire en sorte de
faire face parfois des puissances
continentales comme je disais parfois
des puissances économiques qui exagèrent
garde vous
vous dites que vous différencier de la
liste de conduite par nathalie l'oiseau
de la liste de la république en marche
mais moi ce que vous irez siéger si vous
êtes élu ce qui si on regarde les
sondages est loin d'être le cas pour
l'instant mais ça c'est un autre sujet
les sondages ne font pas une élection et
vous avez l'habitude le soir des
élections de dire le contraire de ce que
disaient les sondages constatant le vote
des français
et puis une campagne électorale c'était
pour ça elle démarre ou est-ce que nous
irons cg c'est très simple nous on fait
partie d'un parti politique européen qui
s'appelle la le dédale de lance des
libéraux démocrates qui sera vain que la
république non parce que monsieur
monsieur gbagbo ne veut pas aller avec
l'ald et ça fait un an et demi que la
halle des lui propose de venir et de
faire un groupe et il a dit clairement
même lame l'oiseau d'ailleurs l'a dit je
crois lors de notre premier débat ils
veulent créer un groupe macro nist avec
avec les socialistes et les anciens
socialistes et sociaux démocrates
européens
écoutez en ce moment par exemple ils
envisagent de le faire avec monsieur
renzi en italique et là la gauche ou la
nouvelle gauche italienne il envisage de
le faire avec le premier ministre
socialiste espagnol
donc c'est forcément pas avec la halle b
c'est forcément pas vous ne craignez pas
vous ne croyez pas que éventuel groupe
que constitueraient les marcheurs à
strasbourg à bruxelles intégrerait
absorberait ce groupe agde et dans
lequel vous vous signeriez d'abord quand
vous arrivez avec une vingtaine de
députés et que vous avez 100 députés en
face de vous c'est pas vous qui absorbé
vous pouvez être absorbées
éventuellement au risque sinon d'être
isolé deuxièmement non je ne le crains
pas et toute façon la question n'est pas
là au lendemain des élections
européennes il va falloir construire une
majorité dans cette majorité il y aura
vraisemblablement le ppe mais qui est
déstabilisé par ce cas une partie
anti-européenne à l'intérieur du bpe
monsieur or bad et même certains des
candidats de monsieur wauquiez deuxième
groupe la halle des kipré semblablement
pourra en faire partie troisième groupe
les verts donc vous voyez personne
n'absorbera personnes et puis si un
petit groupe derrière monsieur macron et
ben il y aura vingt trente quarante
députés européens derrière lui vous êtes
720 sans vous êtes crédité 2% dans l'est
dans les sondages dans la dernière
livraison d'harris interactive
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait le même
choix que les centristes qui ont rallié
la liste des républicains eux ils sont
sur les positions éligibles à ce qu'on a
fait le choix de porter nos idées pas
des valises
c'est assez simple quand je dis que on
ne doit pas diviser
une je voulais vraiment je défends mes
idées
quand je dis qu'on doit augmenter le
budget de la pac et que ça ne coûte pas
un centime parce que les britanniques
s'en allant le chèque que les européens
font de 6 milliards par an chaque année
à comment dirais-je à la grande bretagne
n'a plus lieu d'être
au lieu de baisser de 3 milliards le
budget de l'agriculture on peut non
seulement ne pas le blesser mais
l'augmenter de 3 milliards pour
favoriser à la fois sa transition sa
transition environnementale et une
amélioration de la santé par les
aliments
je pense que c'est bien meilleur entre
guillemets que d'aller porter les
valises sur une liste par dont celle de
monsieur wauquiez de quelqu'un qui a
écrit un livre pour expliquer qu'il ne
voulait plus de l'europe à 27 mais qui
la boulaye à 6 non pardon à 5 parce
qu'il voulait pas du luxembourg autant
dire ne pas faire d'europe du tout le
brouillard est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
vous définissez toujours comme un
fédéraliste roumain présence est devenue
pour nous que personne que c'est comme
une espèce d'anathème comme ça ce que
vous vous dites oui nous nous sommes
fait des rajustements parce que
fédéralisme heureux dire que la france
aurait sous tutelle d'un état je veux
moi que les états se ressemblent pour se
donner de la force actuellement dans des
paramètres fédération européenne quand
par exemple nous demandons ce quelque
chose d'assez simple de garder nos
frontières en commun d'avoir un fbi en
commun y'a pas l'état fédéral au dessus
mais tu en as beihai quand on a un
parquet européen comme vous le demander
c'est quand même des abandons de
souveraineté sur des abruzzes
souveraineté sur ces notions régaliennes
monsieur ne sont pas des abandons de
souveraineté permettez moi de vous le
démontrer un billet européen il
permettrait d'éviter que new frontier
n'arrêtent que nos policiers et
magistrats pendant que des terroristes
pendant que les grands criminels
on passe à travers les mailles des
frontières le parquet il sera évidemment
sous l'autorité de la commission
si vous dites que c'est du fédéralisme
ça veut dire que tout ce que décide la
commission aujourd'hui par exemple la
politique agricole commune c'est fédéral
non ça n'a pas fait sur des corps sur
des questions régaliennes comme ça c'est
des abandons de souveraineté régalien à
ce que la monnaie s'était pas régalien
est ce que la monnaie fédérale monsieur
c'est chez sky et fédéral c'est une
question donc la monnaie elle est gérée
sans exception des à francfort qui n'a
été prise dans les capitales nationales
et les prises avec l'ensemble des
capitales nationales ons qui ont un
représentant qui siège à la banque
centrale européenne
c'est l'instant je vous fais remarquer
qu'on ne l'a pas appelé banque fédérale
ce n'est pas pour rien donc c'est pas la
peine de faire peur aux femmes sans peur
c'est pas la peine de faire peur aux
français ou aux européens d'ailleurs
avec un mot dont la plupart en plus ça
ne veut pas dire la même chose d'un pays
à l'autre donc ça n'a pas grand intérêt
ce qui est intéressant
elles ne sont plus à paris elles ne sont
pas revues dans les capitales sur à
partir du mot ball et bien sûr à partir
sur les politique agricole commune aussi
sur la politique du charbon et de
l'acier depuis plus de 60 ans et donc
est ce que ça a fait de la france le
charbon et l'acier
la police et la justice c'est papa avant
le courage d'assumer des abandons de
souveraineté nationale de partage de
souveraineté qui vous auront déjà je
reviens sur l'exemple que vous preniez
tout à l'heure si on décide et je le
propose d'avoir une stratégie
industrielle commune on permet par
exemple de ne pas avoir la situation où
google une entreprise américaine
seuls aujourd'hui investi 15 milliards
de dollars dans l'intelligence
artificielle tandis que nos 27 pays
séparé investissent 8 milliards de
dollars moitié moins et tout et tout ça
étant séparées et non coordonnées dont
pas efficace nous allons être largué
technologiquement
est ce que c'est un transfert de
souveraineté que de décider de faire sur
l'intelligence artificielle l'ariane où
l'airbus non je voulais rien où l'airbus
c'était des choses qui étaient faites en
dehors de la commission européenne
et on y voir deux gardiens je suis bien
le faire à l'intérieur nous pouvons le
faire à l'intérieur et c'est justement
ce que je souhaite que la commission
européenne fasse
regardez lorsqu'on a fait ariane
lorsqu'on a fait airbus
nos parents nos grands parents nous ont
offert la possibilité le droit de ne pas
comment dirais-je dépendre des
américains ou des russes ou des chinois
pour envoyer des satellites dans
l'espace pour voler dans nos avions et
c'est la même chose qu'on doit faire
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
défends la politique agricole commune
parce que c'est notre indépendance
alimentaire qui est en cause quand je
propose et je hais je le proposais
pardon de l'immodestie je militais
derrière simone veil en 1989 quand nous
proposons des garde-côtes et des gardes
frontières
c'était certes un partage de
souveraineté mais c'est reconquérir nos
souverainetés parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
bien vu ce qui s'est passé en italie
mais enfin monsieur en italie en grèce
il ya des milliers de gens qui sont
arrivés sur les côtes est ce que ça les
a empêché ensuite de balades de
traverser tout le continent non si nous
partageons et c'est ce qu'ont fait mal
et petitement mais c'est ce qu'on fait
avec frontex
si nous partageons la surveillance de
nos côtes la surveillance de nos
frontières on est efficace et on regagne
de la vraie souvent
la différence en réalité elle est entre
la souveraineté d'apparence et la
souveraineté réelle le moment où vous
êtes capable de décider pour vous et pas
de subir ou les événements où ce que
décident les autres à votre place alors
on parlait de parler des s'engage avec
les personnes qui vous ont précédés donc
on a rappelé les 2% qui vous sont
crédités pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
passée de la taille je vous ai dit que
nous portons des idées oui moi je ne
suis pas un pronostiqueur ça peut être
votre travail mais ce n'est pas le mien
je ne suis pas un sondeur je suis un
responsable politique nous sommes une
famille politique qui a toujours été aux
avant postes du combat européen depuis
simone valéry giscard d'estaing trouve
pas rendu dans la liste la liste ma
chronique pardon c'était une hypothèse
ça a duré quelque temps de présence à
plus dur est d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires des journalistes dans la
région quand emmanuel macron évoqué ces
types de cette idée j'ai dit si on est
d'accord sur le projet or sur le projet
pardon quand je propose la fin des
contributions nationales au budget
européen remplacer par une taxe carbone
sur les importations et par une taxe sur
les transactions financières et par une
barque sur les visas pour les touristes
qui viennent en europe
monsieur macro ne dit pas la même chose
quand je propose d'augmenter le budget
agricole monsieur mac on ne dit pas la
même chose quand je propose le fbi est
pardon monsieur je vous propose le fbi
et le parquet européen
monsieur mac on ne dit pas la même chose
quand sur l'environnement quand sur
l'environnement je propose qui est un
livret e sur le modèle du livret a
pour financer le verdissement du
continent c'est à dire que les gens qui
signent des pétitions qui font des
manifestations parce qu'ils veulent
qu'on lutte contre le crime à ils ont
raison contre le changement climatique
et ils ont raison
ces gens là ils pourraient placer leur
épargne au service de ce à quoi ils
croient
eh bien monsieur là qu'on ne le dit pas
et je dirais même assez loin il va pas
assez loin ce jeu c'est surtout qui a
rien monsieur quand excusé le discours
d'athènes sais rien je vais vous prendre
deux exemples jeu bien entendu parler
d'un mais européenne
il n'y a pas d'armée européenne on a
besoin en revanche de construire une
cyber force une cyber armée parce qu'on
est en permanence attaquer du côté cyber
mais d'armée européenne il ya que
l'armée française qui intervient aller à
l'extérieur
et d'ailleurs je propose que le la
commission européenne que le budget
européen puisse contribuer à nos
interventions à l'extérieur parce que
quand nos soldats avec un courage
admirable partent se battre au mali
folle défalqué du défi pardon non non
non non il faut le co financer ça coûte
un milliard 6 par an aux français mais
on se bat pas pour nous quand on combat
des djihadistes au mali ont sécurisé
ensemble de l'union européenne et donc
il devrait y avoir un partage du fardeau
donc vous voyez il ya des il ya je
reconnais volontiers une chose monsieur
macron ne veut pas démolir l'europe les
autres de la démoniaque en revanche
pardon ce qu'ils proposent ou même ne
propose pas ne permet pas de la
révolutionner de la transformer et donc
de la sauver dans les opinions publiques
et dans le rapport de forces entre les
différentes agences
comment on fait pour révolutionner
lorsqu'on apprend aujourd'hui que la
commission entend poursuivre les
négociations avec les états unis sur
l'accord commercial de libre échange
alors que la france est bien macron s'y
opposent est ce que véritablement au
moins on a encore de l'influencé du
pouvoir
alors il s'y opposent parce que les
états unis ne respecte plus les accords
de paris en 60 une autre c'est une autre
question
d'abord les négociations commerciales
c'est un sujet sur lequel il n'y a pas
unanimité nécessaire et je pense qu'il
faudrait supprimer lui même limité pour
beaucoup de décisions parce qu'il vaut
mieux faire à 4 à 6 à 8 quelque chose de
bien que de rien faire avant le cas dans
le cas d'espèce pardon c'est monsieur
mâcon qui de mon point de vue à tort de
ne pas vouloir ouvrir des négociations
ouvrir des négociations ça ne veut pas
dire vous signer l'accord ça veut dire
que vous mettez vos exigences
en face de celle des américains et si ça
ne va pas il faut pas le signer mais
refuser même d'en parler ça ne permet
pas de remettre à plat un certain nombre
de choses et notamment le fait que parce
que nous ne consacrons pas assez
d'argent dans notre défense européenne
nous dépendons de la défense américaine
en échange de quoi ils nous imposent des
lois commerciales que nous ne sommes pas
capables qui nous imposent de la
concurrence déloyale eh bien je pense
qu'il vaudrait mieux en discuter avec
eux y compris en créant le rapport de
force que de fuir la table en tous les
cas la campagne électorale va être mise
un petit peu entre parenthèses pendant
quelques jours sans doute en tous les
cas je le disais emmanuel macron a
décidé de reporter son allocution tant
attendu pourtant ce soir en raison
effectivement de sept incendiés pouvant
table au coeur de paris le symbole de la
capitale avec de notre histoire mais le
symbole de la france à notre dame de
paris avec la charpente
de plus de mille ans qui s'effondre à la
suite de cet incendie qui est évidemment
spectaculaire au coeur de paris et les
couverts aujourd'hui en ce moment même
de fumée noire encore une réaction
peut-être parce que évidemment la portée
symbolique de ce terrible incendie
considérable on apprend que la flèche
delà de notre dame est tombée il va
flèche et prier d'abord j'ai une pensée
pour les pompiers qui sont en train de
se battre et d'essayer de sauver notre
notre patrimoine et ce magnifique
monument
deuxièmement comme je le disais c'est la
mairie de paris qui est propriétaire du
bâtiment et qui aura la charge de
construire il n'y a pas de raison que ce
soit que paris et moi dès ce soir je
demande au maire de paris au président
de la république de lancer une grande
souscription nationale pour sa
reconstruction le drame n'est pas encore
terminé mais on sait que ça y est notre
bijou notre joyau est abîmée alors il
faut que l'on mette tous la main à la
poche c'est pas par les impôts des
parisiens qui vont le faire
c'est par l'ensemble de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui voudront contribuer et moi
je le ferai volontiers contribué à ce
qu'on retrouve ce magnifique mots
violents et cette figure de notre
capital sur l'île de 17 une émotion même
bien sûr très partagés on sait que ce
pays est en quête d'émotions collectives
en voici une
aujourd'hui effectivement tous contribué
très vite à la reconstruction de la
cathédrale vous demandiez tout à l'heure
est ce que ça va créer de la tension moi
je j'espère que ça va créer du
rassemblement on a imaginé que la tour
eiffel s'effondre demain on voudrait
tous qu'elle sera construite on est
presque tous à y mettre la main ou en
tout cas la main à la poche
eh ben je suis sûr qu'il ya des millions
de français qui entendront ce message
les pompiers se battent et vont sauver
tout ce qui est à sauver tout le reste
il nous appartient à nous 65 millions de
français de contribuer à le reconstruire
j'évoquais les tensions avec la
possibilité d'un attentat mais donc les
informations a effectivement accrédite
actuellement à la thèse de l'accident
voilà merci beaucoup pour se respecter
il faut se méfier d'ailleurs cette
obsession permanent mais de se méfier
des emballements jamais alors mais de
tout le monde à chaque fois qu'il se
passe quelque chose c'est un attentat on
a versé via notre compte j'espère qu'on
en aura plus m vielh parc européen nous
y aidera merci à tous mes recevoir a
très vite